[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
philosophie
ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht aber
ich habe manchmal das gefühl wir leben
in düsteren zeiten mit populismus
klimawandel migrations krisen ums
digitale überwachung meine heutiger gast
sagt es geht uns so gut wie nie zuvor
ob wir diese gute nachricht trauen
können das möchte ich jetzt herausfinden
ich freue mich auf's gespräch mit dem
hochdekorierten psychologie schön dass
sie hier
ja herr pinker alles wird besser
gilt das auch für meine dauernd
verstopfte mailbox es wird nicht alles
besser die wichtigsten dinge aber schon
über jahrtausende hatte die
lebenserwartung des menschen bei 30
jahren
heute liegt sie bei 71 jahren im
weltdurchschnitt und in den entwickelten
ländern darüber 80 war das lesen und
schreiben für das privileg einer sehr
kleinen vermögenden elite ist es für
mehr als 90 prozent der menschen heute
selbstverständlich denn die welt heute
weniger kriege in denen weniger menschen
umkommen als je zuvor
die wahrscheinlichkeit in einem
flugzeugabsturz einem autounfall oder
bei der arbeit um zu kommen ist kleiner
denn je wir haben mehr muße stunden fast
alles im leben ist nachweislich besser
als je zuvor in der geschichte
das hat man bei diesem buch gewalt 2011
da haben sie schon versucht zu zeigen
dass die welt vor allem sicherer und
gewalt ignoriert und jetzt das neue buch
aufklärung jetzt da sind sozusagen fast
alle bereiche des menschlichen lebens
abgedeckt mit vielen grafiken sie haben
jetzt schon ganz viele beispiel
gebraucht zeigen sie dass das
menschliche leben eigentlich aufwärts
geht und besser wird ein bisschen kam es
mir vor als wäre das eine art werbe
katalog für die fortschritte der
menschheit das buch beweist den
fortschritt der menschheit
es ist kein werbe katalog oder glaubens
appell sondern fordert dazu auf sich die
fakten anzusehen
mit blick auf die daten im zeitverlauf
stellt man fest dass diese fortschritte
echt sind diesmal überraschen weil wir
in den medien ein verzerrtes bild der
welt vorfindet journalisten können nur
über das berichten was geschehen ist ein
land im krieg eine schule die von
terroristen angegriffen worden ist das
nicht geschieht macht keine schlagzeile
gewalt wird es wohl immer geben in der
wert und entsprechend auch berichte
darüber in den nachrichten nicht
berichten kann man über den relativen
verlauf von gewaltakten womit wir uns
des fortschritts nicht bewusst sind
nur wenn wir sehen wie viele menschen
jahr für jahr in kriegen durch markt
oder an krankheiten sterben oder arm
sind erkennen wir den fortschritt aber
in tat und wahrheit vermasseln dir ja
auch ganz viele viele menschen sind
besorgt über beispielsweise die
verschmutzung der meere über den micro
plastik in der nahrungsmittel das
artensterben dass ihr mitverursachten
oder natürlich der klimawandel zu sagen
dass viele dinge besser geworden sind
heißt nicht dass wir in eine utopie
leben und es keine probleme mehr gibt
viele menschen schließen den fortschritt
aus weil sie so einiges auf listen
können was im moment schief läuft
tatsächlich läuft wie das falsch aber
gleichzeitig hat sich die lebensspanne
verdoppelt ist die armut und die zahl
der kriegstoten stark zurückgegangen es
ist kein widerspruch zu sagen dass wir
bei bestimmten dingen fortschritte
gemacht haben das aber noch probleme
bestehen probleme wird es immer geben
aber viele meinen ja das sind jetzt
nicht einfach nur irgendwelche probleme
sondern das was wachsen heißt ist an
seine grenzen gekommen und wir haben es
übertrieben sie hingegen sagen nein
wachstum das hat uns zum erfolg geführt
und etwas wie der klimawandel ist hat
einfach der negativer nebeneffekt aber
wir werden auch das schaffen
es gibt keine gewissheit dass wir es
schaffen aber wir können es schaffen
wenn wir uns mächtig anstrengen und
vertrauen haben in unsere
problemlösungsfähigkeit unsere heutigen
probleme lösen sich nicht von selbst
anstatt den dingen ihren lauf zu lassen
können wir die herausforderung annehmen
und unseren erfindergeist einsetzen
tatsächlich erfolgte unsere fortschritt
teilweise zu lasten der umwelt sei sich
die lebensqualität nur über energie
steigern lässt
frühere energieträger wie die kohle
führten zu starker umweltverschmutzung
kann aber auf weniger schmutzige
energieformen wechseln von kohle zu gas
von gas zu erneuerbaren energien und zur
kernkraft die keine treibhausgase
ausstoßen
diesen prozess müssen wir vor anstoßen
die fortschritte der reicheren länder
bei der luft- und wasserqualität oder
bei gefährdeten arten gilt es auf die
ganze welt auszudehnen
dafür aber braucht es entwicklung wenn
man sehr arm ist will man als erstes
strom dafür nimmt man luftverschmutzung
in kauf wird eine gesellschaft reiche
kann sie es sich leisten für energie und
saubere luft zu bezahlen
politische maßnahmen können diesen
prozess beschleunigen zum beispiel eine
coole steuer und die unterstützung von
technologien die uns mehr energie mit
weniger verschmutzung liefern zwei dinge
die mich sehr interessieren das eine was
ich gerne nachfragen würde ist sie haben
deutlich gemacht dass sie eigentlich für
atomkraft sind das betonen sie auch
immer wieder dass sie sagen das ist
eigentlich die sauberste form der
energie aber das problem des abfalls des
atomaren abfalls das haben wir ja nicht
gelöst
radioaktiver abfall wird heute auf den
parkplätzen der akw es in den fässern
gelagert und stellt kein riesiges
problem dar
wir werden irgendwann eine lösung für
die endlagerung finden die rettung des
planeten sollte aber im moment höhere
priorität genießen als die frage wo man
diese beton fässer begräbt in finnland
und anderswo laufen bereits planungen zu
tiefen lagern
wir dürfen aber nicht vergessen dass die
alternativen zur kernkraft viel mehr
müll produzieren mit den nebenprodukten
die im abbau anfallen und dem feinstaub
in der luft ist kohle sehr schmutzig
selbst bei der wind- oder solarenergie
fällt abfall an
in 30 bis 50 jahren werden wir ein
gewaltiges problem mit der entsorgung
all der sonnenkollektoren haben die
ersetzt werden müssen was machen wir mit
der gewaltigen menge an materialien
alles hat seinen preis und die frage der
bewältigung des abfall problems stellt
sich überall
sie haben auch deutlich gemacht dass ihr
reicher gesellschaften werden desto
besser können sie eigentlich saubere
energien sich leisten das ist auch eine
these die sie vertreten
nun gibt's natürlich aber auch die
möglichkeit den ökologischen fußabdruck
zu messen und da sieht man ja dass
reichere länder natürlich den viel
größeren fußabdruck haben es ist schon
richtig dass wir zum beispiel in der
schweiz vielleicht nachhaltige energien
nutzen da sind wir gar nicht so schlecht
aber wir verbrauchen unmengen und platz
zum wohnen wir fliegen sehr viel wir
heizen unsere wohnungen vielleicht
inadäquat waren
das heißt in diesen bereichen wiederum
sind wir dann eben sehr viel schlechter
die menschen in entwicklungsländern die
zwar vielleicht kohle benutzen aber
einfach ein sehr viel kleineren
ökologischen fußabdruck haben die
umweltverschmutzung ist am größten in
armen ländern menschen mit dem holz
kohle oder holz kochen das einatmen
dieses rauchs führt zu vielen
krankheiten und todesfällen verseuchtes
wasser ist ein viel größeres problem in
armen als in reichen ländern
ich kann das wasser aus einem wasserhahn
trinken ohne mir sorgen machen zu müssen
ein cholera zu erkranken
natürlich stoßen die industrieländer mit
ihrer großen wirtschaftsproduktion viel
mehr co2 aus umso dringlicher ist der
technologiewandel wir können reiche
länder nicht zu armut verdonnern oder
entwicklungsländern befehlen zu bleiben
das wäre unmoralisch
also müssen wir technologien nutzen bei
denen wir die meiste energie mit der
geringsten verschmutzung erhalten
sonnen und windkraft in verbindung mit
batterie speicherung für die
nachtstunden oder die windhose zeit
diese batterie technologie gibt es noch
nicht aber wir werden sie entwickeln
genauso wie die nukleartechnologie der
nächsten generation kleine modulare
reaktoren die massen produziert werden
wie flugzeug triebwerke bei denen noch
weniger müll anfällt und das
unfallrisiko noch kleiner ist
sie wissen heute nicht welche
technologien kosteneffektivsten sein
wird deshalb sollten wir die technische
entwicklung antreiben
wirtschaftswachstum gründet immer auf
ideen dass fragen der nachhaltigkeit
oder der ressourcenverknappung die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung hemmen
könnten ist eine fehlannahme wir
brauchen nicht die ressourcen sondern
wollen unsere wohnungen beheizen von
einem ort zum anderen gelangen und licht
haben die ressourcen die wir dafür
einsetzen hängen ab von der verfügbaren
technologie und die verändert sich mit
den ideen vor zwei wochen erhielt paul
romer den wirtschafts nobelpreis für
seine these der pflicht das
wirtschaftswachstum nicht auf ressourcen
gründet sondern auf ideen und die sind
unbegrenzt seit dem moment wo ich war
mal das gefühl habe sie sind sehr
begeistert von der menschheit das liest
sich ja auch sehr erfrischend dieses
vertrauen darin dass wir schon genug
lehrer sein werden um unsere probleme
gelöst zu kriegen
es gibt keine garantie dafür dass wir
klug genug sind alle probleme zu lösen
ich bin
ob das auch nicht im buch aber ich
plädiere dafür unser können die
wissenschaft und die vernunft zum wohle
der menschen einzusetzen
ob die natur gesetze der physik und
diesem ziel näher bringen wissen wir
erst wenn wir es versuchen
wir haben keine andere wahl niemand wird
oder bleibt freiwillig arm
wir sollten herausfinden wie wir den
menschen das bestmögliche lieben geben
können sowie nicht krankheit armut
ignoranz analphabetismus und gewalt wie
möglich sei die geringsten schädigung
unserer umwelt warnt wir hatten vor
kurzer zeit den ehemaligen chef des club
of rome bei uns granny max
und er sagt wenn wir wirklich die ziele
erreichen wollen bis 2030 35 prozent
weniger treibhausgase wie es eigentlich
im jüngsten weltklimabericht festgesetzt
ist dann müssen wir unser leben radikal
ändern dann ist fertig mit fliegen wir
müssen wirklich weniger auto fahren wir
müssen unsere ganzen kabeln englischen
es eben wirklich nach unten kriegen
er sagt wir haben die wahl und die
höheren ganz kurz zu besitzen wir haben
die wahl
wenn wir weitermachen wie bisher wird
die existenz der gesamten menschheit in
frage gestellt so viel steht auf dem
spiel
es wird nicht sie oder ihre kinder
treffen aber ihre kinder und enkel
erwartet ein ziemlich unangenehmes leben
und zwar in den nächsten jahrzehnten
schauen sie nur im mittelmeergebiet in
20 30 jahren wird es nicht mehr möglich
sein dort zu leben
es wird kein wasser mehr geben man kann
kein getreide mehr anbauen die leute
werden aus griechenland teilen süd-
italiens oder süd portugals wegziehen
müssen
es wird nicht nur in bangladesch so sein
sondern uns in europa treffen
selbstverständlich müssen wir uns um den
klimawandel kümmern
man darf dabei aber nicht voraussetzen
dass die menschen dafür eine ärmere welt
hinnehmen
und es wird auch nie eine totalitäre
weltregierung geben die die menschen
dazu zwingt mit dem autofahren
aufzuhören
speziell in armen ländern werden die
menschen richtigerweise sagen ihr in den
reichen ländern hat die
energieressourcen ein paar hundert jahre
lang genutzt jetzt ist es an uns wir
wollen mobilität unsere häuser beheizen
oder herunterkühlen
wir können sie davon nicht abhalten und
ja wir können nicht auf demselben weg
bleiben ohne möglicherweise in eine
katastrophe zu laufen aber die
alternative liegt in der verbesserung
unserer technologie und unserer politik
also darin herauszufinden wie man den
menschen die energie geben kann die sie
brauchen und wollen ohne die
treibhausgasemissionen die den planeten
bedrohen
es ist höchst unwahrscheinlich dass alle
dem vorschlag folgen einfacher zu leben
wenn das die einzige wahl ist haben wir
ein gewaltiges problem
wir halten das tun was wir schon immer
gemacht haben unseren erfindergeist
nutzen
man sollte anreize dafür schaffen
energie zu sparen und auf co2 arme
energiequellen zu wechseln über die
bepreisung von kohle und zweitens
technologien für energie ohne
treibhausgas emissionen entwickeln
dieser weg ist sehr viel
wahrscheinlicher die menschen hätten
sehr gerne energiequellen ohne co2
ausstoß man will ehrlich das co2 sondern
die energie technologie die einem die
energie ohne dass co2 gibt es wird mit
größerer wahrscheinlichkeit von
siebeneinhalb milliarden menschen
akzeptiert als wenn man ihnen befiehlt
auf den lebensstandard des heutigen
indiens zurückzufallen heißt das für sie
auch dass dieses wir müssen die leute
dazu bringen andere energieformen zu
nutzen dass der staat dafür sorgen muss
sind sie für eine starke starts der
staat wird eine rolle zu spielen haben
erstens muss er kohlepreisen weil dass
der markt nicht richten kann
es ist die tragik der allmende wobei
einzelne von einer ressource profitieren
die kosten aber auf den ganzen planeten
überwälzt werden
die wirtschaftswissenschaftler nennen
das eine negative extern ali t
um diese situation zu korrigieren muss
jeder für den schaden bezahlen den er in
der atmosphäre anrichtet dadurch dass er
co2 ausstößt und eine co2 steuer ist
dazu am besten geeignet wenn milliarden
von menschen bei den hunderten
entscheiden diese jeden tag treffen für
den angerichteten schaden bezahlen
müssten verändern sie ihr verhalten und
damit reduziert sich die menge an co2
wenn sie zu alternativen energiequellen
zugang haben bei denen keine co2 steuer
anfällt verschiebt sich das
gleichgewicht in richtung erneuerbare
energien und energiesparen
nebst der preissetzung hat der staat
auch eine zweite rolle
die technologie forschung zu
unterstützen die für einzelne firmen ein
übergroßes risiko bedeutet nukleare
technologie der nächsten generation
batteriespeicher zur überbrückung bei
der wind- und sonnenkraft zwar forschen
hier schon einzelne firmen aber wir
wissen dass grundlagenforschung gut ist
für die allgemeinheit aber nicht gut
genug dass genügend firmen hier aktiv
werden und da sind ja eigentlich wieder
auch bei der innovationskraft der
menschheit dass wir in der lage sein
können die sache wirklich anzugehen
ich finde interessanter 7 würde betonen
dass sie kein optimist sind wo sie immer
wieder aus optimist bezeichnet werden
und ich glaube das beste bild dafür ist
das glas sie sagen sie sind nicht jemand
der sagt guck mal das glas ist nicht
halb leer wie ein pessimist sagen würde
es ist auch nicht einfach halb voll wie
ein optimist sagen würde sondern sie
messen das ist ihr ding
sie messen was da drin ist untersuchen
erheben daten und statistiken und dann
sagen sie sich in ein possible ist was
ist das genau
genau so ist es und der maßstab ist
dafür das perfekte sinnbild ich habe den
begriff des zivilisten vom schwedischen
arzt hans rosling und liegt tatsächlich
geht es nicht darum das glas halb voll
oder halb leer zu sehen sondern zu
messen wie viel wasser tatsächlich drin
ist
wir wissen von hans rosling befragungen
dass die menschen falsch liegen in ihrer
einschätzung der welt befragt ob extreme
armut am steigen am sinken oder gleich
geblieben ist aber eine mehrheit der
kinder weltweit geimpft ist schneiden
menschen schlechter ab als schimpansen
weil schimpansen zufalls antworten geben
menschen aber wählen die
pessimistischere antwort und legen damit
falsch die menschen kennen die fakten
nicht
sie wissen nicht dass die zahl der
kriegstoten in den letzten jahrzehnten
zurückgegangen ist
das extreme armut sinkt das
alphabetisierungsrate steigen
das ansteckende krankheiten wie malaria
lungenentzündungen durch erkrankungen
zurück gehen die leute liegen schlicht
falsch und das ist doch interessant sie
haben verschiedene begründungen warum
die leute sich dauernd täuschen sie
sagen eine das hat mich sehr
interessiert besteht darin dass die
leute denken pessimisten sind irgendwie
seriösere wissenschaftler denen kann man
eher vertrauen
aufgrund der unvermeidbaren verzerrungen
in den medien nämlich den berichten über
ereignisse und nicht über trends und
daten haben wir einen psychologischen
hang zum negativen
wir machen uns eher gedanken über
verluste und gefahren als über
verbesserungen und gewinne propheten
eine bühne und angefahren zu erinnern
die wir vielleicht übersehen haben
das intellektuelle leben ist tief
durchdrungen von pessimismus in der
geschichte des westlichen denkens wogten
aufklärung und gegen aufklärung
und hier in unseren universitäten heute
sind viele einflussreiche intellektuelle
gegen alle vernunft tief pessimistisch
die schriften von schopenhauer nietzsche
heidegger sagt den host modernisten
durchzieht ein strom von kulturellem
pessimismus die intellektuelle welt
ignoriert daten fakten und trends
es gehört zu den glaubenssätzen der
intellektuellen dass unsere
institutionen dem scheitern geweiht
group dem zusammenbruch nahe und nicht
nachhaltig sind
das ist ein dogma unter vielen
intellektuellen wie bei den verzerrungen
im journalismus wenn man sein bild vom
zustand der welt von den zeitungen
ableitet wird es folgerichtig
pessimistisch gefärbt und falsch sein
das sind jetzt so die psychologischen
erklärungen warum wir dazu tendieren
eher das negative zu sehen und
tatsächlich sind sie ja
kommunikationswissenschaft dass ich in
psychologie ein hochrangiger breit
dekorierter professor für psychologie
sie kommen aus einer extrem
erfolgreichen familie und mama stellt
man sich dann die frage sind sie
vielleicht auch plausibel ist geworden
weil ihre familiengeschichte natürlich
eine ist wo man sieht da haben menschen
etwas aus ihren möglichkeiten gemacht
interessanterweise war zb ihre schwester
auch schon bei uns zu gast ich weiß
nicht ob sie das wissen susan pinker wie
sieht sie hier am gleichen tisch sitzen
war auch schon bei uns auch sie ist
psychologin und sie sind verheiratet mit
rebecca goldstein
ich habe eines ihrer bücher mitgenommen
mind body problem ein wunderbares buch
ist selber philosophin also ihr eigener
erfolg ist eigentlich vielleicht so
etwas wie das nicht der grund auch ihrer
these nein es wäre hochgradig irrational
wenn ich mein leben mit dem zustand der
welt gleichsetzen würde ich glaube nicht
dass sich so selbst bezogen bin
zum beweis das buch handelt nicht von
mir sondern es enthält 75 grafiken die
zeigen dass die zahl der kriegstoten
zurückgegangen ist das extreme armut
gesunken heisst dass die lesefähigkeit
zugenommen hat da geht es nicht um mich
sondern um die datenlage das stimmt aber
wenn man gutes im leben erlebt hat fällt
es einem vielleicht auch leichter auch
das hotel der welt zu sehen
es ist unmöglich die sinkende armut
kurve in einem diagramm als steigende
kurve zu sehen wenn man ein schlechtes
leben hat da würde man funktionieren
seite meine argumente nicht von meinem
charakter oder meiner glücklichen
situation ab sondern von fast null daten
auf einzelbeispielen gründender
argumente sind intellektuell schlicht
und zu lesen
es hat nichts zu tun mit mir wir sind ja
hier in der philosophie stunde und
kennen alle den as rom ein trugschluss
und wissen dass charakter oder
lebensgeschichte kein gegenargument sind
da haben sie völlig recht ich finde
trotzdem einfach erst einmal interessant
dass sie ja auch recht haben mit dieser
entschuldigung beschreibung dass sehr
viele intellektuelle dazu tendieren die
welt sehr schwarz zu malen
und sie sind natürlich nicht der einzige
und die meisten von ihnen sind
wohlhabend gesund und stammen aus
privilegierten verhältnissen
aber vielleicht können wir da auch an
john stuart mill erinnern der selber der
große liberale philosoph der in einer
rede auf 10 128 gesagt hat dass nicht
der mann der hofft wenn andere
verzweifeln sondern jene der verzweifelt
wenn andere hoffen von den anderen
ausreise angesehen wird und ich glaube
das ist ein stück weit auch ein punkt
ja wir sind beide zuschreibung
moralischer ernsthaftigkeit
voreingenommen wir haben die neigung die
propheten des alten testaments oder
schwarzmaler als seriös tiefgründig und
moralisch und menschen die auf
fortschritte hinweisen als
oberflächliche verkäufern propagandisten
zu sehen
andere sagen dass auch die jugend zum
beispiel oder thomas hobbes wäre das
sogar theoretisch begründete
er sagte konkurrenz um luke für zur
verehrung der alten zeit denn die
menschen streiten mit den lebenden nicht
mit den toten
seine zeit kritisiert zieht man damit
auf seine fahne
wer seit hunderten jahren tot ist den
muss man nicht mehr kritisieren
das erklärt die sehnsucht nach der guten
alten zeit gesprochen über verschiedene
psychologische erklärungen warum
menschen nicht den grafiken trauern
sondern eher ihren intuitionen oder dem
gefühl alles wird irgendwie schlecht
nämlich wegen der medien wegen der
intellektuellen die schwarzmaler sind
und so weiter mich interessiert aber
auch noch wissen menschen wirklich geht
und gerade in den usa hat man immer
wieder gehört von den sogenannten
abgehängten in rust belt wir sprechen
zurzeit sehr viel über die wahlsiege der
afc in deutschland als übermenschen zum
beispiel im ehemaligen ostdeutschland
die sich als abgehängt empfinden oder
auch in frankreich in den banlieues von
paris
denken sie das ist alles jammern auf
hohem niveau
die unterstützung für populisten in den
usa und wohl auch in europa kommt nicht
in erster linie von einkommensschwachen
schichten sondern eher von leuten die
das gefühl haben kulturell abgehängt
worden zu sein und die mit der politiker
correctness nichts am hut haben
es ist diäten schweiße mehrheit der
männer die findet die gesellschaft
kümmert sich vor allem um schwule frauen
transgender und immigranten während sie
und ihre lebensart dabei auf der strecke
bleiben
donald trump wurde nicht zu sehr von den
ärmsten gewählt sondern von leuten aus
dem mittelklasse und den reichen die
kulturell verbittert waren drei wochen
ungefähr
die menschen da einen ultra rechten
kandidaten gewählt zum präsidenten
bauzone euro und da heißt es der grund
für die analysen ergeben
der grund ist einerseits die
wirtschaftskrise die andauernde und
gleichzeitig auch die gewalt da sind
60.000 menschen opfer geworden von
gewaltdelikten innerhalb eines jahres
das sind mehr als in kriegsland in
syrien
in brasilien und viele
lateinamerikanische länder haben denn
auch die höchsten mordraten in der welt
das hat sich zumindest in den usa
gezeigt dass bei einem anstieg der
kriminalität eher konservative
kandidaten gewählt werden
nächsten kam 1968 dank seiner law &
order wahlkampagne an die macht er hat
richtigerweise darauf hingewiesen dass
die kriminalität durch die decke schoss
in den 60er jahren
sie stieg in jedem westlichen land
gewaltig an und politiker wissen sich
das zunutze zu machen
seit den 90er jahren geht die anzahl der
gewaltverbrechen in europa und den usa
zurück
trump behauptet fälschlicherweise die
kriminalität wäre noch nie so hoch
gewesen
aber weil die menschen die fakten nicht
kennen sind sie empfänglich für
argumente der politiker dass etwas gegen
die ansteigende gewalt getan werden muss
in brasilien herrscht in einzelnen
städten tatsächlich sehr viel gewalt so
in der de janeiro waren rate aber auch
schon runter gebracht hat was vielleicht
nicht allgemein bekannt ist aber klar in
brasilien ist gewalt vielmehr ein thema
sind europa oder den usa
aber sie würden sagen wenn die
menschheit insgesamt ansehen dann geht
es eigentlich aufwärts es gibt diesen
ungebrochenen aufwärtstrend auch wenn es
lokal gesehen immer mal wieder einbrüche
gibt und einzelne länder den bestimmten
hinsichten wieder bei klassischer leben
es war ein brocken trend ist nicht
ungebrochen aber doch signifikant wie
gesagt stieg die
kriminalitätsrate in den 60er jahren
keiner dieser trends ist gleichförmig es
gibt immer auch kleinere und größere
ausschläge aber im großen und ganzen
waren die trends positiv wenn auch nicht
überall das wäre ein wunder und völlig
unmöglich es liegt kein widerspruch
darin dass die mordrate global gesunken
ist das aber einige länder eine höhere
mordrate haben als andere und die
schlimmsten länder eine sehr hohe
mordrate um fortschritt zu erfassen muss
man quantitativ denken können ohne ein
perfektes ideal oder eine dystopie vor
augen zu haben dass tobias zurück bei
maßstab
sie haben ein kapitel geschrieben in
diesem buch zum thema glück und das ist
ein unglaublich interessantes kapitel
ein sehr philosophisches kapitel und das
kapitel endet damit dass sie sagen
eigentlich wenn man die datensätze
anguckt müssten die menschen glücklicher
sein und eigentlich sie ihren eigenen
erstaunen sind sie nicht so glücklich
wie sie sein müssten
die menschen sind durchschnittlich
glücklicher geworden
nicht in jedem land in der schweiz sind
die menschen in den letzten 20 jahren
nicht wirklich glücklicher geworden
andererseits gibt es hier wenig luft
nach oben
wisst ihr wo so glücklich wie überhaupt
menschen möglich es ist schwierig sich
vorzustellen dass alle die ganze zeit
ekstatisch vor glück sind unser gehirn
gibt es nicht hier
wir bewerten unsere gegenwärtige
situation passen uns in einem gewissen
maß an
und weil es immer etwas gibt wofür wir
uns fürchten stellen wir uns vor was
alles schiefgehen könnte aber das
bedeutet nicht dass eine verbesserung
der lebensumstände die menschen nicht
glücklicher macht die theorie der
hedonistischen tretmühle besagte dass
ungeachtete lebensumstände man sich nie
glücklicher fühlt weil man sich sofort
daran gewöhnt man geht ständig auf einem
sich bewegenden rolf steigt das gefühl
des glücklichseins passt sich gemäss
dieser theorie an die jeweilige sieht
aktion an wie die augen an die
lichtverhältnisse egal wie reich man
wird egal wie gut das leben man wird nie
wirklich glücklich
heute wissen wir dass diese hypothese zu
stark ist
lassen sie mich an dieser stelle ganz
kurz noaa harari zu wort kommen er war
auch bei uns zu gast und hatte er sein
buch museums geschrieben und er hat eine
glaube ich ziemlich ähnliche idee was
sie genau gerade kritisiert haben hören
dem ganz kurz zu
tatsächlich sind die menschen nicht
glücklicher als zuvor
obwohl ihre lebensbedingungen viel
besser geworden sind
dafür gibt es zwei hauptgründe zuerst
einmal hängt das glück der menschen von
ihren erwartungen ab und nicht von den
objektiven lebensbedingungen wenn sie
bekommen was sie sich wünschen sind sie
glücklich wenn sie etwas wollen egal was
und es nicht bekommen sind sie
unzufrieden und das problem ist je
besser die lebensbedingungen werden
desto größer sind die erwartungen
heute genießen wir zahlreiche dinge von
denen die menschen früher nur träumen
konnten
aber wir sind nicht zufrieden denn wir
wollen vielmehr auch auf einer tieferen
ebene reagiert das menschliche gehirn
auf erfolg und genuss grundsätzlich
nicht mit zufriedenheit sondern mit dem
wunsch noch mehr zu haben
egal was wir erreichen wir wollen mehr
es trifft in diese überspitzung nur
teilweise zu menschen in reicheren
ländern sind glücklicher innerhalb jedes
landes sind die reichen glücklicher und
in den meisten ländern für die wir
zeitreihen haben sind die menschen
glücklicher geworden
es ist also schlicht falsch dass die
schweizer nicht glücklicher sind als die
menschen in togo benin oder im kongo die
schweizer sind glücklicher weil es ihm
besser geht
das heißt aber nicht dass sich die
schweizer nicht auch beklagen oder
sorgen haben aber ihre lebensumstände
sind besser als in afghanistan oder
anderen pigs ländern wie syrien
was
er selbst auch so sehen überall ferrari
uns einige wirtschaftswissenschaften und
psychologen müssen also zur kenntnis
nehmen dass die alte tribüne theorie so
nicht stimmt wiederum mit dem maßstab
jetzt gibt's noch ein argument was ganz
viele in diesem zusammenhang bringen und
auch das sind sie zurück aber ich würde
mich freuen wenn sie dazu kurz was sagen
viele sagen naja dann lass uns doch mal
die suizidraten angucken
die schweiz hat eine hohe suizidrate
togo keine ahnung und das ist
wahrscheinlich das problem oder man
weiss es von vielen ländern einfach
nicht oder warum sind die suizidraten
für sie kein hinweis darauf dass es den
menschen in diesen ländern gar nicht
besonders gut geht
diese geschichte mit der hohen
suizidrate in den ländern mit einem gut
ausgebauten sozialstaat wie die schweiz
oder schweden wie man auch oft hört ist
eine moderne legende
sie stimmt nicht eine grafik in meinem
buch zu suizidrate in der schweiz zeigt
dass sie im neunzehnten jahrhundert viel
höher
selbstmord ist ein weitgehend
unverstanden das phänomen und
paradoxerweise kein perfekter indikator
für unzufriedenheit weil auch
impulsivität und der zugang zu
schusswaffen oder gifte oder zu kohle
gas höfen eine rolle spielen denn
selbstmord einfach ist steigt die rate
man spricht auch manchmal von einem
suisseid happiness paradox wonach die
selbstmordrate in glücklichen ländern
höher sei weil die menschen feststellten
dass sie als einzige unglücklich sind
unzufriedenheit ließe sich ihr aushalten
wenn alle anderen auch unglücklich sind
aber das ist bloß eine theorie aber
durch selbstmordrate in der schweiz
gehört nicht zu den höchsten
sie ist relativ niedrig das ist nur eine
theorie dass das vergleichen unglücklich
macht das ist ja auch eine interessante
frage ober eigentlich ungleichheit und
glücklich macht und auch das weisen sie
eigentlich zurück und sagen nein
weil wenn ein land insgesamt relativ
vermögen dies dann spielt
nicht die ungleichheit gar nicht so eine
große rolle mit blick auf das glück der
menschen in auch zurückhaltend gegenüber
der theorie der hohen selbstmordrate in
glücklichen ländern weil sie auf einer
einzigen studie beruht in den
sozialwissenschaften wissen wir
mittlerweile dass man mit rückschlüssen
warten muss bis sich eine breitere basis
an literatur gebildet hat auch die
annahme dass sich alle mit allen
vergleichen und deshalb trotz besserer
lebensumstände niemand glücklicher wird
hat sich aufgrund der breiteren
datenlager falsch erwiesen
reichere länder und reichere menschen
innerhalb eines landes sind glücklicher
natürlich im durchschnitt je nach
naturell einzelne sind genetisch
glücklich als andere und die objektiven
lebensumstände verändern die
lebenszufriedenheit tatsächlich wenn man
noch einmal darüber nachdenkt was könnte
die menschen eigentlich unglücklich
machen geht natürlich immer mal wieder
auch um die frage welchen einfluss
eigentlich religion hat und sie sind
jemand der klar sagt wir sollten uns
verabschieden von religiösen idealen das
ist eigentlich nicht auch wir sprechen
daher gleich über das thema der
aufklärung nicht ein ein ideal der
aufklärung dass wir uns im glauben
vergraben
aber es gab immer wieder auch diese
vorstellung neuer gott ist eine
tröstende idee vielleicht und philipp
blom ein berühmter historiker aus
deutschland der hat einmal gesagt uns
menschen uns vermögenden menschen den
menschen denen es gut geht kommt der
transzendentalen traum abhanden die
haben nicht mehr diese vorstellung dass
es noch einen trost gibt jenseits des
ganzen materialismus aus was wir uns da
so kaufen können was machen sie mit
diesem vorwurf dass sie eigentlich
keinen trost bieten können mit diesen
datensätzen
ich unterscheide zwischen religion
einerseits also der institution den
ritualen dem symbolismus der
gemeinschaft und dem glauben an gott
andere
die annahme dass die moral von gott
kommt dass man nur deshalb ein guter
mensch ist weil man sich vor dem
jenseits verrichtet halte ich nicht für
sehr gesund es gibt auch keinen beweis
für ein leben nach dem tod
natürlich würde ich einer gläubigen
person die nach dem verlust eines lieben
menschen trost sucht den glauben an ein
wiedersehen nach dem tod nicht ausreden
das wäre schlicht grausame generell
sollten die menschen ihr leben nicht im
lichte dessen gestalten was nach dem tod
kommt sondern auf das hier und jetzt
ausrichten
die idee dass das leben auf der erde von
geringer bedeutung ist und nur einen
winzigen teil unserer existenz ausmacht
für zum märtyrertum zu
selbstmordattentaten und in der
inquisition oder während den
religionskriegen zu zwangs konversion
unter todesdrohungen
wir sollten uns darauf konzentrieren
dank menschliche mitgefühl und
menschlichem erfindergeist das leben auf
der erde heute zu verbessern
krankheiten zu heilen und lieben zu
senken aber man kann doch noch einmal
die frage stellen woher kommt der trost
für die existenzielle sorge für die
existenzielle angst die uns menschen ja
auch ausmacht das verzweifeln an der
sinnlosigkeit des daseins sozusagen
da sehen wir ja das vielleicht eine
statistik uns einfach nicht hilft wir
lassen uns nicht überzeugen davon was es
uns besser gehen sollte wenn wir uns
einfach nicht besser fühlen
es gibt existenzielle aspekte der
conditio humana mit denen wir schlicht
und einfach klar kommen müssen wir
werden sterben
das ist nicht eine frage des glaubens
sondern eine tatsache
wir müssen unser leben im listen und
unser sterben gestalten
experten darin kurz denn dazu gehört
sein leben auszuschöpfen und sich
anderen gegenüber so zu verhalten wie
man es für sich erwartet da wir alle
gleich ist bedeutet sein leben aktiv zu
gestalten
die menschen die einem am wichtigsten
sind zu lieben das leben anderer zu
verbessern
etwas zurück zu lassen nach seinem tod
den tod zu akzeptieren für zu besseren
weiteren und nützlichen entscheiden hass
zu denken dass die 70 oder 80 jahre hier
unbedeutend sind weil nur das
himmelreich zählt philosophisch gesehen
leuchtet mir das vollkommen ein was sie
sagen ich denke nur es gibt ja ganz
viele menschen die haben so genannte
bullshit jobs mal den titel zunehmend
von david gray das buch also jobs die
sie überhaupt nicht erfüllen um jobs von
denen sie denken die bringen auch nichts
wirklich nützliches zu tage und was ist
mit all diesen menschen wenn sie jetzt
haben ist eigentlich ein appell etwas
aus unserem leben zu machen ein paar
kisch und freundlich zu sein zu anderen
menschen
viele menschen fühlen sich vielleicht
gefangen in einer existenz in der sie
nicht den eindruck haben diesen ideal
nachkommen zu können
der vorstellung im himmel bis in alle
ewigkeit harfe zu spielen wird er auch
nicht viel helfen
vielleicht müsste man auch das konzept
der busche jobs überdenken und
intellektuellen beobachte ich einen
mangel an respekt für jobs die menschen
mit dem lebensnotwendigen weil damit
kein annehmlichkeiten ausstatten
das ist eine welt die ich kenne
ich stamme aus einer kleinunternehmer
familie ein großvater verkaufte
krawatten main
autoteile ein vater kleider
intellektuelle sollten die idee
überwinden dass man nur mit geistiger
arbeit oder kunst etwas wertvolles in
die welt setzt sich der unordnung
auflösung armut dem chaos entgegen zu
stemmen ist nicht unwirklich wäre mit
seiner arbeit dazu beiträgt den menschen
kleider und nahrung ein zuhause und
unterhaltung zu geben zu einem dreisten
sie sich leisten können tut etwas
wertvolles das intellektuelle sind
schlicht krank wenn sie das beachten
dass die menschen brauchen und wo kommen
wir zu diesem thema der aufklärung
aufklärung jetzt das ist eigentlich ein
buch das sein plädoyer ist für die
aufklärung wenn man über die aufklärung
spricht dann finde ich immer das bild so
eingängig des sogenannten dogmatischen
schlummert das ist das bild von immanuel
kants der gesagt hat wir sind in diesen
dogmatischen schlummer gefangen um die
müssen selber denken wir müssen uns
quasi erheben und wagen zähler zu denken
worin besteht der dogmatische schlummer
der menschheit zurzeit besteht darin
ansichten ohne hinreichende residenz
gute gründe oder logik zu übernehmen
weil sie der gängigen meinung oder einem
religiösen oder politischen
ideologischen glaubenssatz der extremen
linken oder rechten sprechen
oder man sich beeindrucken oder vom
eigenen bauchgefühl leiten
all dies sind quellen der
selbsttäuschung von fehlern zum
ansichten die mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit war sind kommt man
einzig über vernunft und evidenz schön
dass wir hier in einer philosophischen
sendung sind die diesen idealen gewidmet
ist
wo im moment über die aufklärung zu
sprechen
in seiner abschiedsrede gesagt die
verdanken sehr viel der mediale
aufklärung wiederum emanuel makro bei
seiner antrittsrede hat gesagt die werte
der
steuerung sind bedroht meinen die alle
immer das gleiche und auch dasselbe wie
sie oder ist das auch einfach so eine
werbe floskel geworden wir machen jetzt
mal ein bisschen auf aufklärung
sie sprechen durchaus über dasselbe wie
ich und ich zitiere sie auch beide in
meinem buch ich bezweifle aber dass
aufklärung unfug ist angesichts der
gegen aufklärerischen welle des
populismus
hier wird die nation rasse oder
ethnische gruppe über die gesamte
menschheit gestellt die wissenschaft
ignoriert da wo es einem passt in dem
man an ein bauchgefühl appelliert und
nicht an logik und vernunft
ein führer die tugend auch die seele der
menschen verkörpert im gegensatz zu idee
der demokratie in der einführer nur ein
verwalter auf zeit ist stimmte zeitlich
befristete entscheid befugnis die sich
aus der rechtsordnung ergibt die werte
der aufklärung sind tatsächlich durch
den aufkommenden populismus sowie durch
andere bewegungen bedroht
deshalb ist es wichtig für diese werte
einzustehen
man muss auch nicht von aufklärung
sprechen kosmopolitismus die offene
gesellschaft gemäß karl popper
liberalismus oder klassischer
liberalismus obwohl diese begriff viele
bedeutungen hat oder humanismus tun es
auch liberalismus ist ein gutes
stichwort einig dass auch sehr
interessiert ich habe ihr buch auch aus
ein liberales projekt gelesen
man könnte also dann weil sie zum
beispiel auch ganz klar sagen die müssen
kämpfen gegen tribalismus wir müssen
kämpfen gegen nationalistische
verbrennungen wir müssen kämpfen gegen
fundamentalisten die die leute einengen
in ihrer freien denkweise zum beispiel
nun könnte man aber auch sagen wenn dir
wirklich sozusagen fast schon zu ziehen
testen werden wenn wir den daten glauben
und nur noch den dazu glauben dann
brauchen wir das liberale projekt
eigentlich gar nicht mehr und damit
meine ich wir brauchen nicht mehr
offenheit und toleranz
weil wir können einfach immer messen die
müssen gar nicht mehr
tolerant sein wir können ja einfach
messen der recht habt
und eigentlich ist das doch fast wieder
gegen ein liberales projekt da wären wir
dann fast schon bei einer gesellschaft
die vielleicht intolerant wird weil es
nur noch darum geht wer richtig messen
kann der die daten richtig auslegt ich
sehe die verbindung hier nicht wirklich
dachte der politischen überzeugung will
man wissen wie die realität funktioniert
und das kann man nicht ohne zu messen
niemand von uns ist hellsichtig wir
haben keine vision der wahrheit
wir müssen uns die welt betrachten so
wie sie ist und das bedeutet daten zu
erheben und zu messen was man dann mit
den daten macht hängt von den werten ab
die man hat und hier spielt der humanis
aus eine rolle
wissenschaft als solche in ihrer
beschreibung und erklärung der welt sagt
uns nicht was wir tun sollen
dafür braucht es die menschlichen werte
in bezug auf gedeih glück gesundheit und
das leben der menschen und andere
empfindungsfähigkeit das ist der
letztendliche moralische wert den sie
wird aber die wissenschaft nicht einfach
so er kommt genau der humanismus
eigentlich ist das ja eine ethik ohne
metaphysik kommt von der möglichkeit des
perspektiven wechsels von der
unvoreingenommenheit der einsicht dass
ich nicht anders bin als sie und dass
ich deshalb keinen verhaltenskodex haben
kann der besagt dass gut ist was für
mich gut ist und sie zur hölle fahren
können das ginge nur wenn ich der
herrscher des universums wäre niemand
aber ist herrscher des universums ich
muss sie vom wert der verhaltensregeln
überzeugen auf die wir beide uns
verständigen können und daraus entsteht
moral moral beruht auf
unvoreingenommenheit auf den
kategorischen imperativ dem schleier des
nichtwissens der goldenen regel alles
verschiedene wege hin zur idee dass
keiner einzigartig ist dass unsere
interessen gleich wichtig sind
es gibt auch eine empirische komponente
wir wissen dass bestimmte
verhaltensweisen dazu führen dass es
allen besser geht
es mag ja gut sein für mich wenn ich
ungestraft stehlen vergewaltigen töten
und alles tun kann was ich will
es wäre aber weniger gut wenn alle
anderen dies mit mir machen könnten
also muss ich mich bereit erklären mein
eigenes verhalten einzuschränken
damit das auch die anderen tun und wir
alle so ein besseres leben haben ein
leben auf das wir uns im vornherein
verständigen können es ist die alte idee
des gesellschaftsvertrags kontrakt wenn
wir über diese werke sprechen wie die
werte des humanismus über die werte der
aufklärung leben in vielen politischen
reden im moment eine große rolle spielen
dann sagen sie auch es sind ich auch
sehr interessant wir sollten das nicht
vertauschen mit der rede von den
westlichen werten
das ist eine engführung zusagen
aufklärungs werte sind nur westliche
werte absolut es geht hier nicht um
westlichen chauvinismus
natürlich stammen viele der ideen der
aufklärung die überdauert haben von
westlichen denkens irgendwoher müssen
die den ja kaum dass sie vom westen her
rühren macht sie auch nicht per se gut
oder schlecht
viele dieser gedanken heutige verdanken
die anderen teilen der welt
so kam die idee des gewaltfreien
widerstands als mittel für soziale
veränderungen von gandhi die idee der
versöhnung und der restaurativen justiz
anstelle von strafe und vergeltung kam
von mandela und tutu in südafrika die
aufklärung bündelt gute ideen egal woher
sie stammt und umgekehrt stand der
westen ja auch nicht unverbrüchlich zur
aufklärung nach dem aufkommen der
aufklärung entstand sofort die
gegenbewegung es folgten nationalismus
romantische militarismus faschismus
kommunismus in den totalitär
marxistischen ländern die alle durch aus
westlicher länder sind
die aufklärung ist also nicht
deckungsgleich mit dem westen
wenn sie sagen dass sie nicht westliche
werte meinen sie damit ja auch sind
nicht nur irgend von der quelle her
westliche werte sondern auch in ihrem
geltungsbereiche sind die werte die wir
aus menschheit teilen sollten
das heißt eigentlich müsst ihrem buch
anschließend auch ein bildungsprojekt
ich kann es denn gelingen die menschen
zu begeistern für dieses projekt der
aufklärung
das geschieht ja schon in einer gewissen
weise die welt hat sich für mehrere 70
jahren der universellen
menschenrechtserklärung verpflichtet
muslimische länder china christliche
länder westliche nicht westliche länder
alle kamen sie überein dass die
menschenrechte die würde des menschen
die das recht auf bildung und
gerechtigkeit universell
angesichts der unterschiedlichen
kulturen bezweifelte man damals dass es
gelingen könnte alle länder auf einen
kodex zu verpflichten aber das gelang
und als die vereinten nationen vor
wenigen jahren die ziele für nachhaltige
entwicklung vorschlugen darunter
armutsreduktion zugang zu sauberem
wasser umweltschutz rechte von frauen
bildung waren sämtliche länder dieser
welt einverstanden
das sind durchaus aufklärerische ideen
da geht es nicht um religion um gottes
gebote und das leben nach dem tod und
kein nationalistisches gedankengut was
er unmöglich wäre
denn bestünde das moralische hauptziel
darin zu zeigen die vereinigten staaten
wären die leuchtende stadt auf dem hügel
wären vielleicht die amerikaner damit
einverstanden aber sicher nicht indien
japan frankreich oder die schweiz
der ausgleich zwischen unterschiedlichen
menschen verläuft in einen natürlichen
prozess in dem partikularinteressen
prozent risches und rassistisches denken
sowie religiöse moral nichts zu suchen
haben
weil andere damit nicht einverstanden
wären angesichts der notwendigkeit das
ein verständnis der ganzen welt zu
erhalten könnte man befürchten dass bei
der suche nach dem kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenner nichts substanzielles
herausschaut und die moral auf der
strecke bleibt
aber wir wissen heute wie in der
nachhaltigkeitsziele und der
menschenrechtserklärung dass dem nicht
so ist
wir sind alle menschen homo sapiens und
wir wissen dass wir uns in vielem
ähnlich sind wir alle leben lieber als
dass wir sterben sind lieber gesund als
krank gebildet als ungebildet haben
lieber essen als dass wir hungern sind
lieber sicher es in gefahr
das sind die moralischen werte auf die
sich alle verständigen können dass sie
sagen naja aber die gefahr ist auch das
irgendwie in diesen datensätzen und in
den beobachten und messen auch so etwas
wie ein darwin ismus herrscht und da
gibt es einfach so weil man auf der fit
ist und dann werden wir mal sehen wie es
den geht die schwächer sind in der
gesellschaft und da sagen sie nein der
humanismus wird zuerst kommen der red
uns davor bewahren einander einfach
umzubringen wenn wir nicht taugen in
einer gesellschaft humanismus hebt sich
ab von der ideologie des
sozialdarwinismus ja übrigens nicht auf
darwin zurückgeht sondern auf herbert
spencer der darüber für darwins
entstehung der arten schrieb die idee
dass es gut ist der natur ihren lauf und
die starken die schwachen verdrängen zu
lassen ist das gegenteil von humanismus
system jedes wesen mit einem bewusstsein
und leidensfähigkeit die möglichkeit
erhalten soll zu gedeihen und nicht zu
leiden
das ist nicht die art und weise wie die
evolution funktioniert aber so
funktioniert eine spezies homo sapiens
der sich dank seines großen gehirns
überlegen kann wie er leben will
anstatt von der evolution getrieben zu
werden mit unseren großen gehirnen
können wir ethische systeme formulieren
die sich sehr von dem unterscheiden was
die ungebremste natur mit sich bringen
würde
lassen sie mich zum schluss noch auf die
digitalisierung zu sprechen kommen weil
ich interessant finde dass in diesem
zusammenhang mit der digitalisierung ja
auch sehr viel über die werte der
aufklärung gesprochen wird und dass es
heißt wir müssen irgendwie einsehen dass
wir ganz dringend wieder um verleben
selber in die hand nehmen müssen und
unsere autonomie unsere selbstbestimmung
verteidigen unsere privatheit
verteidigen
interessanterweise schreiben sie nicht
so viel über die digitalisierung in
ihrem buch das hat mich erstaunt das
buch ist ohnehin schon lang genug sich
viele setze mich dem oberflächlichen
trend in den medien bezüglich social
media jedem neuen medium wurde bei
seiner einführung sämtliche sozialen
missstände angelastet dem buch gibt dem
roman radio fernsehen intellektuelle
machen es sich zu einfach wenn sie jede
technologie mit der zwei ihre kinder
aber nicht dieselbe vertraut sind für
alle probleme verantwortlich machen
natürlich haben die social media neue
probleme mit sich gebracht
aber ich glaube der trend alles auf die
social media zu schieben ist
oberflächlich und falsch das heißt auch
meine erste frage an sie
ob auch meine verstopfte mailbox besser
wird die haben sie auch gar nicht
beantwortet sie denken die probleme da
die lassen sich von selber da werden die
eben ein nettes programm finden und dann
werden nicht mehr so viele eltern kommen
jetzt ja kein problem löst sich die
tatsache dass vieles besser geworden ist
bedeutet nicht dass die dinge von selbst
besser werden
das ist ein oft missverstandene aspekt
des fortschritts konzept diene werden
nur besser weil wir herausfinden wie wir
probleme lösen können die verschiedener
probleme durch soziale und digitale
medien müssen unterschiedlich und
gleichzeitig angegangen werden
instanzen zur fakten überprüfung gegen
die welle der verzerrungen durch fake
news könnten hilfreich sein
einen anderen ansatz auch das mein
problem wie wir miteinander interagieren
damit wir nicht hinter unseren
bildschirm verschwinden und unser leben
von der bildschirmzeit aufgefressen wird
selbstkontrolle und weisheit ausgewogen
das sind unterschiedliche probleme
und bei beiden müssen wir schauen wie
wir die vorteile der neuen technologie
nutzen können ohne unter den nachteilen
zu leiden
ich weiß nur wenn man ihn in einen e
mail schreibt dann kommt eine autorität
dass sie sehr beschäftigt mit diesen
beschlüssen und nicht so schnell
antworten können
das ist eine möglichkeit
ich versuche das richtige maß zu finden
findet zeit die naturfreunde mein
familienleben zu genießen
beim schreiben stelle ich mein e mail
ein paar stunden lang ab du nicht
gestört zu werden
ich habe keine mitteilungen auf meinem
mobiltelefon oder meinem computer diese
ständige gebiet sollen eine neue e-mail
kommt ist eine idiotische funktion die
man aber abstellen kann ja sicher auf
tour und wozu ich jedem raten
ich habe mal eine postkarte halten
darauf stand wenn das die lösung ist
dann hätte ich gerne mein problem zurück
ich glaube ich habe heute gelernt die
probleme sollten wir nicht zurück wollen
aber die lösung die braucht eine
anstrengung von uns allen
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich für
dieses gespräch
diese finca vielen dank nächste woche
doppeln wir gleich nach mit den großen
stimmen unserer zeit trifft den
soziologen richard sennett in berlin zum
gespräch über städte und menschen am
kommenden mittwoch steht der nationale
themenabends day talent auf dem programm
und der geht uns alle an susanne wille
fragt was der digitale wandel für uns
und für die schweiz bedeutet mit
dokumentarfilmen reportagen und live
gesprächen ab 5 nach 8 auf diesen sender
eine gute woche und bis bald
[Musik]